a quick update on the free david pakman
show flash drives we have a bunch of
32-gigabyte
david pakman show flash drives last year
we offered some of these with
memberships and I mentioned yesterday on
the program that I had 12 of these that
I could give away for free to anybody
who signs up for a yearly membership
32gig david pakman show logo flash drive
free six of those have been spoken for
and I have six left okay so if you're
interested we'll just send you the flash
drive that's it and you can use it 32gig
sign up for a membership it's got to be
a yearly membership okay at david
pakman.com slash membership you go there
you switch to the yearly tab select any
yearly membership as inexpensive as 60
dollars a month but 60 dollars a year
but if that is a little higher than the
price you're looking to pay on the
second page of the signup process you
can use the coupon code
I voted seventeen and typing in that
coupon code will save you 40% off of
your membership whether you pay full
price or whether you pay the discounted
rate you qualify for a free 32 gigabyte
USB flash drive you just have to email
me ideally right after you sign up for
membership you say hey David I want one
of those last six flash drives here's my
address and if you're not sure if you
want to verify that there is a flash
drive available for you just email in
before you sign up and say hey I'd like
one of those flash drives is there one
still available and if there is I will
get back to you and then you can sign up
so six of those left forty percent off
coupon code
I voted seventeen the only rule is it
must be a yearly membership which will
be only 36 dollars if you apply that
coupon code I think that's a pretty good
deal people that people are telling me
that it's an absolutely fantastic deal